is the door to Ironman totally closed
cuz I don't believe it is oh you guys
can go through time now you can go
there's there was you know you already
opened up that door let me ask you the
question if I pick the jersey back up
and put it on wouldn't you feel a little
bit like oh no crap no oh
here's what here's the right thing they
go through a few semi lackluster
Avengers movies without you
you ready for this I'm ready here's the
scene there's a moment where the world's
fate is at stake and they've realized
they need a super genius and then they
figure out how to restart that time
machine great come on is that you the
audience sees you when you step out of
that thing is this your and can we you
wanted a little arc on it too because if
this is your idea then you got to show
up for it too I'll do it I'll show up
what have to do I don't know I'll do
whatever I have to do we all have to do
whatever Kevin Feige thing they do they
do it's digital
I hold that digital thing I'll do it but
did though the way people would freak
out if you came back mm-hmm come on
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Iron Man Avengers 5
video you probably saw the news because
Robert Downey jr. has been doing all
this press for his new non Marvel movie
people have been asking him about coming
back as Iron Man this just happens to be
one of the more compelling pitches that
he's heard so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of Easter eggs in here
inadvertently Joe Rogan does reference
some very specific Avengers stories
maybe without realizing it so if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos we're doing
a new infinity saga box that giveaway
for all the blu-rays all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about how to bring Iron
Man back without completely undermining
his sacrifice because that's the big
question and they kind of address it
during this Joe Rogan clip so how do you
bring him back without completely
undermining that great moment the
Avengers end game ending when he snaps
vanos away Robert Downey jr. also talks
a little bit about some cool moments
hanging out with the other Avengers
actors after all this happened in real
life when they're not busy filming stuff
because a lot of them don't see each
other that often in real life we'll just
bring this down top 5 style starting
with number 5 so Joe Rogan's first big
go-to for just
defying that he come back is actually
from a more practical standpoint Marvel
tries a new Avengers movie without
including him or our big team up movie
and it performs terribly at the box
office by comparison really good example
that is Avengers endgame it is the
highest-earning movie in the history of
movies now that was that whole big run
why they re-released it in theaters just
so they could past James Cameron's first
Avatar movie just so they could cross
the finish line and say we have the
highest-grossing movie of all time
now James Cameron is totally gonna come
back with the avatar sequels and be like
I'm gonna try and beat that again
so obviously the line is gonna keep
pushing forward but the thing that Joe
Rogan also addresses when he's talking
to Robert Downey jr. about Iron Man
coming back is that they tried these
movies without him and he suggests that
maybe they don't please the fans as much
it just doesn't go nearly as well for
Marvel as they would want and that
creates a real desire from a financial
standpoint to try and find a way to
include him in another Avengers movie
bring him back somehow like is there a
way we can do this without it sucking
and being a total cash grab because
movies are made to please fans but
mostly Studios make movies to earn money
so number four when Joe Rogan is
pitching Robert Downey jr. his idea for
bringing him back his second big go-to
is time travel
he says they have time travel now and
after an Avengers movie with you doesn't
do well they grab a version of Iron Man
from a different point in the timeline
he steps out of the time machine to a
big reveal and everyone in the theater
flips out I do totally buy that reaction
as long as he didn't come back in Doctor
Strange 2 multiverse of madness which is
the next huge crossover mini Avengers
movie Captain America Civil War style
because it's got Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Strange ripping the multiverse
wide open but the story Joe Rogan is
inadvertently referring to when he's
trying to pitch this time-travel idea
maybe without realizing it is Young
Avengers young Avengers is mostly known
for being a time-travel heavy franchise
came to conquer one of the most famous
young avengers villains also one of the
most famous Avengers level time-travel
villains that Marvel has not used yet I
love you as Iron Man so I would I would
if you if they opened up this time
machine and you popped out I just
imagine the moment where everybody goes
in crazy it would be amazing it'd be
great so number 3 WTF Marvel and Kevin
Feige have spoken publicly about
have they been considering a Young
Avengers movie or a Disney Plus series
for a long time now just a question of
setting the table in terms of
introducing the characters in the story
concepts that you would need for that
movie time-travel is a really good
example you have to introduce concepts
in the MCU before you do big movie based
on that concept like they introduce the
concept of the multiverse in the first
Doctor Strange movie then they
introduced the quantum realm in the
first two ant-man movies then during
Avengers endgame they combine those two
concepts and lean on them really heavy
to create their solution for saving the
universe now that they've introduced
time-travel to the MCU they can use it
as a story device in a much bigger way
in a new movie
young Avengers is just the perfect movie
for that they've even almost introduced
half of the original comic book young
Avengers team or will by the end of
Marvel phase 4 you have teenage Cassie
Lang aka stature she's the same basic
powers as ant-man in the wasp
there's the iron lad character last seen
during Iron Man's funeral at the end of
Avengers endgame she-hulk is gonna debut
during the Marvel phase for she-hulk
series if they're not gonna do the whole
Kling character I've also heard rumors
about him but we know that they're doing
she-hulk there's the cape bishop hawkeye
that's debuting during the Hawkeye
series and then Wiccan in speed that
seem like they're coming
during the Scarlet Witch Wanda vision
series there's still a couple years to
decide which characters they want to
include but there were six original
Avengers on the first team I think there
should be six members on the first
version of The Young Avengers team just
for that nice symmetry and if Robert
Downey jr. really wants Joe Rogan to
participate like if I'm doing it you're
coming with me you can give him a cameo
as himself like Joe Rogan just passing
by them on the street number two the
next big solution for bringing Iron Man
back without completely undermining his
sacrifice would be to have a major
Marvel villain try to steal his legacy
in a much bigger more literal way than
Mysterio did think about what Norman
Osborn did in the comics after Civil War
in the events of Dark Reign the Dark
Avengers twisting the legacy of Iron Man
in a way that's cool but also feels so
wrong that you want something to happen
to bring them down there's a cool twist
on bringing Iron Man back just to slap
Norman Osborn around you could totally
do that without having to bring Tony
Stark back from the dead you can do it
with an artificial consciousness of Iron
Man in the comics he's backed up his
consciousness many many
times they kind of iced his body after
Civil War - for a hot minute you had a
Jarvis version of Iron Man wisecracking
his way through the comics helping out
the heroes assessing the villains even
though I wasn't a huge fan of that comic
book run in general I know you were all
keen to have dr. doom show up in the MCU
that time when Ironman became an
artificial intelligence the person that
came to try and literally steal his
legacy was dr. doom but the big twist
with that event in the comics is that it
was dr. doom trying to be a hero
not like Norman Osborn iron patriot
during the Dark Avengers we've seen
rumors that dr. doom is going to be the
villain a black panther - I don't know
if those rumors are true so if they're
not gonna go straight for Norman Osborn
in the sinister six movie dr. doom would
be the next option for that but here's
the big thing though number one WTF it
seems very obvious that the sinister six
is being teased in the Morbius trailer
and all the spider-man crossover stuff
the Sony Marvel are cooking up with the
vulture showing up at the end of the
Morbius movie after watching that scene
it really does feel like a sinister six
movie is happening within the next
couple of years after spider-man 3 at
some point so it would be stupid to not
introduce an MCU version of Norman
Osborn at some point to be the man
pulling all the strings longtime comic
book sinister six fans will remember
that Doctor Octopus created the first
sinister six team but there's still a
mysterious quote-unquote benefactor
villain in the MCU the sunny birch was
working for during ant-man in the wasp
they had billions of dollars to throw
away and they didn't take no for an
answer
they're only a couple of characters in
the comics that are capable of doing
something like that and we know sinister
six is happening at some point it just
makes sense that that person in the MCU
would be Norman Osborn let me know in
the comments though based on what Joe
Rogan is pitching for bringing Iron Man
back if it does go down that way what
would you want that to look like
bringing him back using a time-travel
twist how would they do that without
undermining his sacrifice during
avengers endgame and i got to go have
dinner with a bunch of the Marvel folks
last night and kinda have just a little
bit of extra closure because you know
the movie came out and it you know was
bananas and the directors are sending me
pictures of like people flipping out in
theaters when Tony snaps and I was like
whoa this is kind of like a really big
cultural thing but then like Victoria
Alonso who's the head of VFX are all
these movies a literal super genius or
Kevin Feige or Favreau or Scarlett or
some people that I've just have been
there with it for a long time we we we
were there experiencing it all when it
came out and then we see each other on a
red carpet and it's not intimate and
then we kind of hadn't really had a
chance just to do nothing just hang out
and you know have some crudité and kind
of talk [ __ ] it was a bunch of big
Marvel phase four movie announcements
this past week I'll try to do videos for
a lot of that stuff as soon as possible
leave all your requests in the comments
below
so everyone click here for my brand new
Avengers evil Captain America a teaser
video and click here for my new Doctor
Strange two x-men video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]